well it's not often we start the show
with something from cnn that is actually
true but credit where credits do check
this out from their chief national
correspondent and anchor of inside
politics john king a couple of days ago
the biggest first year priorities of a
president whose calling card was getting
things done
remain unfinished business president
biden said elect me i can get things
done democrats run both chambers of
congress narrowly i get these issues are
highly complicated but it will get to
the substance of the specifics of the
issues in a minute but this is a major
failure
a major failure there seem to be rather
a lot of those with this biden regime in
fact when you look at the metastasizing
number of major failures you inevitably
come to the conclusion that this whole
biden thing you know let's rig the
democrat primary to keep bernie out by
putting in a totally talentless
completely corrupt obviously senile
machine politician this whole biden
thing is a total failure it's not just
the failure of his legislative agenda
that's the good news any reasonable
person would want that to fail the giant
spending bill designed to turn america
into a european-style centralized
welfare state child care healthcare
eldercare everything run from washington
dc by a monstrous federal bureaucracy
the so-called voting rights bill a
blatant attempt by democrats to rig the
election rules nationwide gussied up as
some kind of vital step to save the
republic from the assault on democracy
in the 2020 election yeah the election
which saw historic numbers of people
voting including among all racial groups
but you know if we don't pass this bill
now it's the end of america or something
so the failure of his legislation that's
the kind of failure we can take
but the rest of biden's failures they
hurt
they hurt americans and they hurt
america
remember this
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm not going to shut down the country
i'm going to shut down the virus
what a joke
nearly a year into it the biden regime's
handling of the pandemic is a complete
fiasco to use the language they used
about trump biden has now killed more
americans even though thanks to trump
blasting through the bureaucracy biden
had the benefit of vaccines and
treatments from the first pandemic death
to trump's last day in office 400 000
americans died we've more than doubled
that under biden in less time blood on
his hands
biden's entire pandemic response is a
giant bureaucratic mess of incoherence
and misinformation just this week he
said this
how about making sure that you're
vaccinated so you do not spread the
disease to anybody else what about that
what about that is that that is not true
you useless line fool
even your own cdc director says it's not
true
vaccines are working exceptionally well
they continue to work well for delta
with regard to severe illness and death
they prevent it but what they can't do
anymore is prevent transmission
it's non-stop lies and misinformation
biden's still running around i suppose
we should say stumbling around saying
this
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
the unvaccinated not the vaccinated the
unvaccinated that's the problem
oh is it is it really de biden's nurses
sorry aids
even tell him what's in the news cornell
university they just reported nearly 900
new cases with 97 of the students
vaccinated virtually every case of
omicron has been found in fully
vaccinated students so we've even had
three shots as instructed by biden and
fauci worse still the panicky idiots who
run cornell university have sent
everyone home even though the students
are barely at risk
because they're still like so many other
idiots in our ruling elite nearly two
years into the pandemic pushing the
utterly failed and discredited fouchy
dogma of trying to stop all infections
instead of protecting the most
vulnerable
it's the biggest public policy failure
in history and instead of correcting it
they're lying to try justify it none of
it works none of it makes sense
unbelievably fouchy and of course they
all take their cue from him still
pushing mask wearing even though it's
been totally debunked
you are outside in indoor congregate
settings where you do not know
the vaccine status of people
then you should be wearing a mask
he knows masks don't stop the virus he's
the one who first said so right at the
beginning i don't know what we can do
about a ruling class that just lies like
this in order to boss us all around the
cdc's own study published in may last
year shows there's almost no evidence
surgical masks and cloth masks work and
no that's not medical misinformation
youtube it's medical fact it's science
and if you want to hear the absolute
definitive science-based case against
forced mask wearing do not miss an
extended conversation i had recently
with dr scott atlas on my california
rebel base podcast here's a clip the
argument about mass
is over okay it's over number one
because widespread mass don't work the
size of the virus is smaller than the
hole in the surgical mass okay
and if you've ever worn glasses or
sunglasses while you're wearing a
surgical mask i mean if you're like me
you know your glasses fog up the virus
spreads my breathing uh it doesn't take
a genius to realize that the virus is in
the air that goes out of your mouth and
around and through the mask but that
that's just common sense and that may be
asking too much of people these days
dr atlas took us through all the studies
all the evidence
the episode is out next week so make
sure you follow california rebel base on
youtube and apple and all the usual
places
biden's entire pandemic response is a
total failure just as his economic
policy is a total failure look what he
said
about inflation
just pops up a little bit that was in
june and half a year later we're at a 39
year high surprise surprise if you put
out a massive rescue bill when the
economy is already recovering wage war
on domestic energy production and pay
workers to stay home costs go up and
prices go up
biden's foreign policy is a total
failure except according to him his
surrender to the taliban and disastrous
afghanistan withdraw the worst foreign
policy humiliation in america's history
guess what biden calls it
extraordinary success of this mission
such an extraordinary success that
parents in afghanistan are selling their
own daughters
to afford food and the entire population
is likely to fall into poverty in a
matter of months
everything collapsing in disarray his
iran policy his china policies russia
policy he's offended the french cave to
the germans and forgot the australian
prime minister's name while he was
literally announcing a new alliance with
him
biden ran on uniting the country it's
almost the only thing he ever said from
his basement burbling on about the soul
of america
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal
failed at that too thanks to biden we're
more divided than ever and it's his
party the democrats driving it now we
have 37 percent of young democrats
saying they won't be friends with people
who voted for the other side compared to
just five percent of republicans saying
that
and these democrats are the people who
lecture the rest of us about intolerance
and divisiveness and hate
it's hard to believe how bad this all is
this clown car biden regime they can't
run the pandemic response they cannot
run the economy they can't run foreign
policy and yet they want even more
control over the things they don't run
now what to show us just how much they
can screw that up to
crime in the cities chaos at the border
crt in the classrooms traffic jams in
the ocean outside the ports worse after
biden tried to fix it
everywhere you look it is falling apart
failure after failure after failure
everything they touch turns to crap
easily the worst president we've had and
now even his own party is asking if we
can take it much longer hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else